a Florida teacher says she's under
investigation for showing a movie to her
students that includes a gay character
now we could say a thousand different
things about this the right wing
hellscape that Florida is becoming under
Ron DeSantis we could talk about Free
Speech we could talk about don't say gay
the area I want to focus here is it has
been alleged that by showing the movie
the teacher is giving an opinion about
LGBT people this is ridiculous I can't
think of anyone that in 2023 would deny
that LGBT people exist and the fact that
a movie was shown with an LGBT character
only means that the movie reflects
reality
period